fashion it's something that genuinely
interested me and confuses me at the
same time maybe you feel the same way
maybe you don't care okay great
okay so you're telling me this this is
not confusing to you yo you telling me
this
this gucci face mask is not confusing to
you can you imagine wearing this while
robbing a bank hand over all your money
but you only really have so much money
you're goddamn right I do something I've
noticed lately and maybe you have as
well it's been going on for a while
fashion and memes are becoming more and
more intertwined gucci is the prime
example of memes and fashion coming
together a few years ago they even did a
campaign purely based around memes to
sell their watch and you know what it
was actually pretty good when he buys
you flowers instead of a gucci watch
relatable buy milk call mom wash car new
watch that's the thing it actually
worked they actually pulled it off
pretty well I have to say I think that's
really interesting because a lot of
brands try to use memes in their
marketing as a way to appeal to a
broader audience but it rarely works we
have so many cringe-worthy examples of
this is failing completely like Xfinity
have they're the meme scenes Finity
presents the meme steams I don't like
where this is going it is crazy fast
almost as minou
you don't know what you're doing here
and of course the classic eating spicy
goodness like bars it's spicy goodness
like a boss yikes
but probably one of the reasons why
Gucci was able to pull it off is because
memes and fashion make sense in a way
although I'll be lying if I said it and
confused me this is the first piece of
clothing that shows up if you go to
Gucci's website gucci has really been
the forefront of the me me movement
maybe that's not true actually but
they're one of the bigger ones what is
this
they're just clearly just taking the
pace they have to be the fall and winter
hey you want a dress like this one only
a couple grand and you can look like
this it almost feels like a social
experiment of getting all these models
in and being like can we trick these
models into thinking they're actually
showing off our clothes anyhow if you
look at Gucci maybe ten years ago you
get very different type of looks it's
very plain it's very simple it's very
clean very cut and dry their brand
represents very much how memes work it's
loud it's colorful it's obnoxious
it doesn't take itself seriously you
know what used to be a parody is now
written becoming reality in a way
and other brands have embraced this
fashion meme pretty literally you have
betterments another great brand I like
they had this famous raincoat where they
wrote literally the definition of a meme
at the back of it and their clothing
really represent the whole idea of loud
not to snot serious this guy literally
even looks like me what is this I
thought it was so cool and so different
for having the goofy glasses when I
displayed my merch well turns out it
alter reality PewDiePie already exists
excuse me lady I think those pants are a
little too big
another another brand that embraces the
meme is Balenciaga you probably seen
these look at this dude okay I honor an
aquiline how much is it 1,500 oh well I
see a guy which has the famous sneakers
the triple-s which are this these
gigantic colorful sneakers I remember
when I was in Japan all day all the
Japanese kids have big shoes these $800
sneakers and I was so confused by it I'm
like how did all these kids afford these
items there's no way I think whoever
designed these was just like how much
can we [ __ ] with sneaker heads and make
the worst shoe ever made that they still
will probably buy go on I think I think
the bike ones re are pretty cool no all
right you probably don't care that this
is so random for me to talk about but I
do think it's very interesting how these
these brands have embraced this
different look on fashion completely and
you have these classic brands like Gucci
and Louboutin that used to be very clean
very simple only high-class people
really buy these items because they're
the only ones that can afford it and
have any reasons to buy it but now since
people want to buy into that feeling
they'll feel over being very luxurious
they don't just want to buy that but
they also want to display that you know
people people are just gonna buy an
expensive item they clearly want other
people to know that it's an expensive
you wouldn't know that this is all
Louboutin well it's pretty clear on this
outfit clothing really is such a huge
part of our language and the expression
is you are what you eat but it really
should be you are what you consume you
know obviously people want to associate
with these luxury brands and it's become
so popular especially with Soundcloud
wrappers which are practically memes
themselves you know colorful loud
obnoxious this exact same thing little
pomp embracing gucci gucci gang even
tattooing it on himself that's how hard
they want to be part of this brand
savage 21 with saint laurent takeshi 69
is they all the same thing when me and
Marcel were in Japan we stayed there for
a month and we lived in the fashion
district so we were constantly
surrounded by people very often wearing
the exact same type of clothes or the
same brands at least I felt like I had
to buy the same type of brands because I
wanted to belong you get that feeling of
you want to be part of the group and I
think that's largely why so many kids
now are just buying into this hype beats
meme because people want to feel like
they belong they're part of it which
there's nothing wrong with of course I'm
not judging that I just find the
interesting of men's fashion especially
had just takes such a massive shift
because of it because usually high-class
clothing used to be so preppy but now
luxury items is available for anyone to
wear even if you're not into that type
of style they with the hypebeast it's
really more about a sporty type of look
so you can wear expensive items while
still not feeling like you're too far
off from yourself this is just me
speculating there's no hard facts here
but I think that's why high pace has
become so popular all the kids want to
show that yes I have money when in
reality they're probably just spending
whatever money they have on these
expensive items or
their parents to buy it just so they can
feel like they're part of the group I'm
not an exempt from it I feel the same
weight like I said when I was in Japan I
really was like oh I want to buy this
because everyone else has it you know
it's hard to ignore it even if you are
aware of it
supreme is such a brand example because
usually they're famous for just
literally slapping the logo on it's like
yes hello I am wearing supreme as well
how do you do and that's the thing about
memes as well die really the relates to
passion because memes is being part of a
group as well it's part of being a joke
group how look we understand the same
joke that's why memes are so obscure so
that you feel like oh I get it
other people probably don't get it but I
get it so I I belong in this joke group
I wonder if I could get away with
charging hundred sixty pounds for a
sweater people were so mad at me and
Marcia for is a completely signed up our
hoodie for a hundred dollars which is
ethically produce as well which means it
cost more and and the margin that we put
on it it's super fair but people got so
angry meanwhile let me just buy the
supreme like how these turtleneck with
the logo on this side are becoming more
popular now as well hmm what confuses me
the absolute most about this fashion me
movement is who buys the stuff who is
buying these things like the shoes okay
alright they're crazy but they're kind
of cool I get it
but that face mask who buys that face
mask who's buying it okay and that's the
thing you go here on Gucci's website
like okay not my style I would not wear
any of these but then you have this and
it's like huh that's actually pretty
cool I quite like that how do you go
from this clean-cut and nice
all right to this is that there just to
promote this there's anyone buying these
I'm so confused
who's buying the face mask
I don't understand 200,000 likes I'll
buy it for a meme I just don't get it
really really is that as you would have
you seen anyone wear this have you seen
anyone wearing this it just hit me that
someone should just make a completely
mean brand and just create these obscure
clothing items but super high prices on
them and people will just buy it because
it's expensive and it's loud and it's
out there and it just hit me that's what
people are doing that's what's happening
god dammit Hey
alright that's all I had to say do you
agree with me do you disagree don't get
me wrong though I do really like a lot
of these brands and I find it very
interesting to see this change and
development it fascinates me because
what we decide to wear really tells a
lot about who we are for real the fur
ilda I will get that facemask 200,000
likes let's get it alright bye
[Music]